over the last few decades
computer hardware has evolved in ways
that
we can't even describe from mice and
monitors to graphics cards
cpus and everything in between our
modern machines are
far removed from the gray blocks of our
parents
you mean you can take a movie and he'll
put it on the hard drive and you can
show it back
yeah oh come on yeah yeah there it is
right here
but there is one piece of computing
hardware that has
truly survived the test of time having
barely been changed at all some might
even go as far as saying that this
particular device
was actually better 30 years ago than it
is today
i'm talking of course about every
gamer's
favorite punching bag the keyboard
a keyboard is broken again
[Music]
you see back in the 80s keyboards were
expensive
and respected pieces of machinery that
were built to last a lifetime
but as computer ownership dramatically
increased throughout the 90s
keyboard build quality took a back seat
to mass production
leading the peripheral into becoming
more of an afterthought
however all of that is starting to
change
and thanks to hobbyists flourishing
reddit communities and the growing
influence of esports and streaming we're
experiencing
a keyboard renaissance what was once
considered an
overlooked boring component bundled in
with your pc for free
is slowly becoming the mainstay of any
sexy setup
and at the center of it all is nathan
teja kim
a 26 year old software engineer turned
keyboard messiah
whose love of peripherals knows
no limits
nice no rattle we often fill our senses
with
rich flavors and pleasant aromas but how
often do we take
care in the things we touch to me the
mechanical
keyboard is a tactile gateway to the
computers we build our lives around
especially in this digital day and age
it's also one of the most
underrated and misunderstood pieces of
technology in just a few years
taeha has become to keyboards what
salvador amasukua is to basketball shoes
what hattori hanzo is to japanese steel
so how did this soft-spoken jazz loving
cat dad
turn his passion for building keyboards
into a career
in content creation and more importantly
how has he essentially become the
armorer for some of gaming's
biggest stars dude this thing is nuts
oh my god
all right guys before we dive into
teja's story please take a second to
like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications for a chance to win
a free custom mechanical keyboard
just like this one oh oh we're not doing
that
oh can i keep the keyboard i can't keep
the keyboard
so who the [ __ ] gets it okay so if
you've never watched a teja stream
before
there are a few things you'll pick up
pretty quickly
the first is that he loves cats
he's a big fan of jazz
[Music]
and unlike most streamers he regularly
takes breaks for exercise
but most importantly the man
loves keyboards like a lot
like if someone said i could use a
thousand dollars
to buy the next key cult keyboard versus
use that a thousand dollars towards a
trip
[Music]
i'd probably take the key cult
9.5 out of 10 times also has my logo
engraved
internally
[Music]
that side view look at this
side view oh my gosh you want me to
taste test
a key
oh ah and that infatuation with switches
and caps
has not only made teja a beloved member
of the mechanical keyboard community
but it's also led to him becoming the
most
watched maker and crafting streamer on
twitch you all know how you convinced
your mom
you just go to your mom be like would
you rather pay for my drugs
or a new mechanical keyboard pick your
poison mom
teja's foray into the rabbit hole of
mechanical keyboards began when he was
constructing his first
high-end pc build in college but at the
time
i had a friend who knew more about
parts than i did and i asked him for
some peripheral recommendations
and one of them was a keyboard he
recommended a really nice one at the
time
and i was like wow that's kind of
expensive but you know might as well do
it i'm going to type on a keyboard for
the rest of my life coding but that's
what i thought
before long teja was building his own
keyboards and
sharing asmr style videos which let's be
honest is pretty much
keyboard porn on youtube
ah anyway about
seven months into his youtube adventure
teja found himself
inundated with questions from his
viewers and to better serve them
he decided to try his hand at streaming
i'm already spending you know several
hours building a keyboard might as well
see if like
i can talk to random people all the time
while doing it now in the beginning
teja had about 30 die hard viewers
watching his every move
but by 2019 his stream had grown so much
that he was able to quit his software
engineering job at ibm
and fully commit to content creation
during this time
he even put together the world's first
vinyl
entirely devoted to the pure
unadulterated sounds of custom keyboards
rattling away at 140 words per minute
although teja was having fun making his
asmr content
it was still quite niche so it wasn't
long before his focus
shifted from that towards esports and
gaming
if you look at a lot of streamers like
they have hand cams or like keyboard
cams
and if you're like into gaming you
really invest into your peripherals
i thought you know why not reach out to
some of the gamers the top gamers and
streamers on this platform to see if you
know
they're making a decent amount of money
why not invest in their desk setup
initially teha took on custom keyboard
projects for the likes of btmc
dizzy pengu and skara but
it was in early 2020 that he landed his
biggest commission yet yeah tifu
ended up following me a couple months
ago last year i slid into tifu's dm
i noticed he got a custom keyboard so i
said hey
i saw you got a custom keyboard but if
you want something more luxurious
let me know after some back and forth
with the fortnite phenom
teja came up with an incredible
one-of-a-kind design
for the low price of 3
500 american dollars sweating right now
dude
i'm nervous here goes nothing dude it's
just a keyboard right
oh [ __ ] i thought i had to put the keys
on they're already
on there oh my god dude this thing is
nuts oh my god
look at dude it's so clean you guys can
reach out through it and when tifu
unboxed his bespoke board in front of 30
000 viewers on twitch
teja went from niche to mainstream
like that the video garnered 7 million
views and teja's channel
exploded overnight no longer was teja
cold calling for new customers
they were actively coming to him and
then i found out about cutie pie but i
met him at twitchcon last year he
stopped by my booth he liked keyboards
that i had on
channel not the channel on in my booth
months later he reached out
he wants a keyboard and he had a he had
a specific theme in mind the theme that
he wanted was he wanted it to look
like the the og gameboy
color and the purple polycarbonate kind
of see-through look
sounds magical when it gets locked in
my left thumb died for cutie pie purple
polly big nut
is going to be the new wave of 2020 it's
already started the purple poly wave has
already started
novel keys and rama already hopping on
it
that's pretty nice as of 2021 teja can
barely keep up with the demand for his
services
but despite the fact that most of his
time is spent on new builds for twitch's
growing
stable of stars teja continues to expand
his arsenal of content
he's even spun off his own gaming
channel
called teja snipes just so people can
see him putting his keyboards to work
66 and three kidding me oh my goodness
and therein lies the true beauty
of what te hai is doing he's been able
to take his passion for a niche
subject that on the surface can appear
dry and technical
and turn it into something accessible
and fun
he hasn't just created an educational
platform that entertains
unites and indoctrinates keyboard nuts
but a vibe that anyone can tune into
and enjoy
[Music]
oh he's about to steal
at the end of the day whether he's
soldering pcbs
recommending keycaps or politely
[ __ ] on mass manufactured
monstrosities
teja has become the trusted face of
keyboard enthusiasts
everywhere and he's achieved that
without
taking himself too seriously yes if you
guys aren't aware i do have a only fans
now
called pipes don't actually subscribe to
it
expecting lewds or nudes i am not
intending to post any of that kind of
stuff i just wanted to claim the account
and say i haven't only fans for some
reason it has three subscribers
don't expect anything regardless of
where teja's content takes him next
it's hard to bet against him succeeding
because while it may be the flashy
keyboards and
smooth jazz that draws fans in
it's his laid back style and general
positivity
that keeps all of us coming back for
more
thank you guys for stopping by today
so until tomorrow
see you nerds
now tejas snipes is sick dude i love
watching that man play cs go
yeah we should cue yeah we should cue cs
go i'll carry you in cs
and you teach me to lube switches for my
next build that's the deal i want this
man to
i want this man to bestow his his wealth
of keyboard knowledge upon me we do
two videos dimitri and tape like
counter-strike and dimitri and tail
build a keyboard